This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目主要探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都感觉不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它，收听学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，以艰难的方式成长。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉勒斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们，相信我，宝贝》（the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）播客，可在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（the psychology of your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we begin, I wanted to let you guys know those of you who lived in the US that we are going on a mini podcast tour. At the kind of middle to end of August, I will be going to Seattle, Boston, Chicago, and there are tickets still available. Each night slash afternoon, we'll be doing a small live podcast recording plus a Q&A. Then there'll be a chance for you to get your book signed if you have a copy of my book,
很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析二十多岁的心理学。在开始之前，我想告诉大家，特别是住在美国的听友，我们将举办一场迷你的播客巡回演出。在8月中旬到月底左右，我将前往西雅图、波士顿、芝加哥，目前还有票在售。每天晚上或下午，我们都会进行一场小型的主播现场录制加上问答环节。然后，如果你有我的书的副本，将有机会让你的书获得签名，
person in progress, and then just really mingle with me and other listeners of the show, make new friends, have a glass of wine, have some snacks, and just kind of get to know each other. So if that is something that interests you, if you are ready to, to meet some like-minded people and myself. There are a couple of tickets still available for some select cities. I'm going to leave a link in this episode description. Hopefully I can see as many of you there as possible. Okay, let's get into the episode.
《成长中的人》（person in progress），然后只是真正地与我和节目的其他听友交流，结交新朋友，喝一杯葡萄酒，吃点零食，互相了解一下。所以，如果这让你感兴趣，如果你准备好结识一些志同道合的人和我自己。部分精选城市仍有少量门票在售。我将把链接留在本集节目简介中。希望能在现场尽可能多地见到你们。好的，让我们进入本集的正题。
Today, we are tackling a topic that feels very personal to me, very recently personal to me. We are talking about OCD. If you guys don't know, and you probably don't because I've actually never talked about it before, so this is probably new information to everyone. I was recently diagnosed with OCD, and it is a diagnosis that in retrospect and in hindsight has been a long time coming. For so long, I thought I just had anxiety, and I thought I had a panic disorder. I thought I just have panic attacks.
今天，我们要探讨一个让我感到非常私人、最近才变得非常私人的话题。我们要聊的是强迫症（OCD）。如果你们不知道，而且你们可能确实不知道，因为我以前从未谈过这个，所以对所有人来说这可能是个新信息。我最近被诊断出患有强迫症，回顾过去，这个诊断其实早就该来了。在很长一段时间里，我都以为自己只是有焦虑症，以为自己患有恐慌症。我以为我只是会经历恐慌发作。
And this is where all my issues with thought spiraling, repetitive thoughts, rumination. This is where it all comes back to. I'm an anxious person. But at the end of last year, I began to kind of realize, wait a second, I actually don't really have panic attacks. You know, probably only had like three or four in my lifetime. And I'm actually not an anxious person. I don't get anxious meeting new people. I don't get anxious trying new things. I don't get randomly anxious throughout my day. I don't even get anxious when my life is really busy. The only time I'm really anxious or I would say, you know, distressed is when it comes to this very specific loop of thoughts that I can't get out of about very specific things. For me,
这就是我所有思维打转、重复想法和反复咀嚼问题的根源。这就是这一切的归宿。我是一个焦虑的人。但在去年年底，我开始意识到，等一下，我其实并没有真正的恐慌发作。你知道的，我这一生可能也就经历过三四次。而我其实也不是一个焦虑的人。我在结识新朋友时不会感到焦虑。我在尝试新事物时不会感到焦虑。我在白天也不会无缘无故地感到焦虑。甚至在生活非常忙碌时我也不会焦虑。我真正感到焦虑，或者说我可以说感到痛苦的时候，是当我陷入这种非常特定的、无法摆脱的关于特定事物的思维循环时。对我来说，
primarily my health and like this grand philosophical concept of like death and existence. But other than that, I don't really have anxiety. And at the end of the end of last year, I kind of had a mental health flare up, which I talk about on the podcast. podcast. And that kind of caused me to go and see a new therapist, someone I'd never spoken to before. And when I walked in, I was like, I'm not going to put any label on my symptoms. I'm not going to say, oh, I have depression. I have anxiety. I'm just going to describe how I'm feeling and I'm going to see what she has to say. And after a while, she kind of said to me, have you considered the fact that you may have OCD? And it just kind of clicked for me. I definitely didn't.
主要是我的健康，以及像死亡和存在这样宏大的哲学概念。除此之外，我其实并没有焦虑。而在去年年底，我的心理健康状况出现了一次“大爆发”，我在播客中也谈到过这一点。这促使我去看了一位新的治疗师，一个我从未跟她交流过的人。当我走进去时，我想，我不会给自己的症状贴任何标签。我不会说，哦，我有抑郁症。我有焦虑症。我只会描述我的感受，然后看她怎么说。过了一会儿，她对我说，你有没有想过你可能患有强迫症？这对我来说就像是突然开窍了。我绝对没有
go in thinking that. I was just like, oh, this is a theory. I want to test out. Something doesn't seem right around the diagnoses I've been given. And in that moment, I was like, wow, you know what? Yeah, you're probably right. I spent my whole life talking about psychology, talking about mental health, and I kind of got it wrong. How was this never apparent to me? How come I didn't realize all along that this is what was really going on? And throughout the episode, hear some things around specific symptom patterns and obsessive, obsessive patterns that were very indicative from an early age that just kind of were missed. And I think the reason that they were never apparent to me or to anyone else is that no one ever talked to me about OCD in a way
带着这种想法进去。我当时只是想，哦，这是一个我想检验的理论。我被给予的诊断似乎有些不对劲。而在那一刻，我想，哇，你知道吗？是的，你可能是对的。我花了一生时间谈论心理学，谈论心理健康，而我却弄错了。为什么这从来没有对我很明显？为什么我一直没有意识到这才是真正发生的事情？在整集节目中，你会听到一些关于特定症状模式和强迫性模式的事情，这些在很小的时候就非常有指示性，但却被忽略了。我想，它们之所以从来没有对我或其他人显现出来，是因为从来没有人以一种
that related to my experiences or that I could understand. When we talk about OCD, it was, and it has always been, even when I was at uni and I was studying psychology, it was so surface level. It was so surface level and I could never really see myself in the descriptions, the descriptions of cleanliness and organization and neatness and tidiness. But that is really just the tip of the psychological iceberg here. OCD is so multidimensional and the reality of it is far more intricate, far more debilitating and frankly a lot more deep than the tidy, neat, clean, stereotypes really suggest. Also, you know, for so long, OCD has just been a punchline of so many jokes. I don't think any mental health disorder has been as trivialized as OCD. But if you're living with it, it's so complex and it's pretty freaking relentless, if I do say so myself. And I think
与我的经历相关或者我能理解的方式跟我谈论过强迫症。当我们谈论强迫症时，它曾经是，而且一直是——甚至当我还在大学里学习心理学时——它是如此流于表面。它是如此流于表面，以至于我在那些关于清洁、组织、整洁的描述中永远看不到自己的影子。但这真的只是这里心理学冰山的冰山一角。强迫症是如此多维度的，其现实远比整洁、干净的刻板印象所暗示的要复杂得多、削弱力量得多，坦率地说，也深刻得多。还有，你知道的，长久以来，强迫症一直是许多笑话中的笑点。我不认为有哪个心理健康障碍像强迫症这样被轻描淡写。但如果你正与它共同生活，它是如此复杂，如果你让我说实话的话，它是相当无情的。而且我认为
our society is really lacking in an understanding of this and lacking in how many people are actually walking around with thoughts, really serious, scary thoughts they can't get out of their head. And how many people are suffering because of that? And it really sometimes has nothing to do with the tidy kitchen or hand sanitizer or whatever, like order in their life. It goes so much deeper. So today, you know, given my diagnosis was almost six months ago now, I really want to do a bit of a deep dive into what OCD actually is now that I feel like I know more. I want to dissect some of its core components, the obsessions, the repetitive behaviors, both visible and hidden. And also the vast and very varied ways that OCD can show up in our lives,
我们的社会对这一点的理解真的很匮乏，对于有多少人脑海中正充斥着那些无法摆脱的、非常严重且吓人的想法，这种认识也很匮乏。有多少人因此而痛苦？有时候，这真的和整洁的厨房、免洗洗手液或生活中的某种秩序毫无关系。它要深刻得多。所以今天，鉴于我的诊断距今已经快六个月了，既然我觉得自己知道得更多了，我真的很想深入探讨一下强迫症到底是什么。我想剖析它的一些核心组成部分：强迫观念，重复行为（包括看得见的和隐藏的），以及强迫症在我们生活中可能表现出的广泛而多样的形式，
why it's often confused with other mental health disorders, why it's made fun of, and also what is happening in our brains. I also really want to discuss some of the treatment options, the ways in which you can find relief if you are suffering from OCD. I feel like there will never be a time on this podcast where we don't finish on a high note. And I try not to make it or make it seem like it's toxic positivity, but I do think with things like OCD with any mental health disorder, with anything that we're going through, there is actually a lot more. hope than there is despair. And there are really smart people who have come up with really amazing ways to deal with this and to address the things that are going on in our brains and in our minds and in our
为什么它经常与其他心理健康障碍混淆，为什么它会被嘲笑，以及我们的大脑中究竟发生了什么。我还非常想讨论一些治疗方案，如果你正受强迫症之苦，可以找到解脱的方法。我觉得在这个播客里永远不会出现没有以积极的基调结束的时候。我尽量不去制造或者让人觉得这是有毒的正能量，但我确实认为，对于强迫症这样的事情、任何心理健康障碍、我们正在经历的任何事情，实际上都存在着比绝望更多的希望。而且有非常聪明的人想出了非常了不起的方法来应对这种情况，来解决我们的大脑和心灵以及我们的
bodies. So that's really where I want to leave the end of this episode with a bit of a brightness on the horizon, a bit of a silver lining. I will say, before we begin, small caveat this episode is not for diagnostic purposes. If you think you may be suffering from OCD, please go and see a registered psychologist or a psychiatrist in your local area to get help. My real aim for this episode is just to kind of provide a bit more information about my own story, why it's actually not a rare story, and also, yeah, just kind of provide you with some information, general information around what this disorder really means for people who are enduring it, because I think we could all really benefit from knowing more about the lived experience of people with OCD, whether you have it or
身体中正在发生的事情。所以这正是我想要在本集节目结尾留下的东西：地平线上一丝光明，一线生机。我要说的是，在开始之前，有一个小小的声明：本集内容不用于诊断目的。如果你认为自己可能患有强迫症，请去咨询你当地的注册心理学家或精神科医生以获得帮助。我制作本集的真正目的，只是为了提供更多关于我自己的故事的信息，说明为什么这其实并不是一个罕见的的故事，同时，是的，只是为了向你提供一些关于这种障碍对那些正在忍受它的人究竟意味着什么的一般信息，因为我认为我们所有人都能从更多地了解强迫症患者的生活经历中受益，无论你是否有强迫症，还是
whether you don't. So without further ado, I don't want to say excited for this episode. I'm very invested in this episode and it was a real pleasure and really personally motivating to research it. So I hope you get something out of it. Let's go into the complex origins, symptoms and experience, but also treatments for OCD. Stay with us. Let's kick things off by firstly just busting some myths because honestly the popular image of OCD wildly off the mark. It is not about being a unique freak. It's not about being particular about details. Whilst some individuals with OCD do experience symptoms related to order and cleanliness,
没有。废话不多说，我不想说我对这期节目感到兴奋。我对这期节目投入了极大的热情，研究它是一种真正的乐趣，对我个人来说也是一种强有力的激励。所以我希望你能从中有所收获。让我们一起来探讨强迫症复杂的起源、症状和体验，以及它的治疗方法。请继续收听。让我们首先通过打破一些迷思来拉开序幕，因为老实说，大众对强迫症的印象严重偏离了真相。它不是关于成为一个独特的怪胎。它不是关于对细节过分挑剔。虽然一些强迫症患者确实会经历与秩序和清洁相关的症状，
that is just one facet and it doesn't do justice to what is really happening under the surface. So what is OCD for a very basic perspective? At its core, OCD is actually one of the most prevalent mental health conditions in the world. And every time I tell people that, they're always surprised. But it's true, about 1 to 3% of the population has OCD. And if that doesn't sound like a big amount, I will say that makes it the fourth most diagnosed mental health condition in the world. Coming under depression, generalized anxiety disorder and panic disorder. And if we translate 1 to 3% into a number, that's around 78 to 234 million people worldwide.
但这只是一个方面，它并不能公正地反映表面之下真正发生的事情。那么，从非常基础的角度来看，强迫症是什么？在其核心，强迫症实际上是世界上最普遍的心理健康状况之一。每次我告诉别人这一点时，他们总是感到惊讶。但这是真的，大约1%到3%的人口患有强迫症。如果这听起来不像一个很大的数字，我要说的是，这使其成为世界上第四大被诊断出的心理健康状况。排在抑郁症、广泛性焦虑症和恐慌症之后。如果我们把1%到3%转化为一个数字，那意味着全世界大约有7800万到2.34亿人。
And let's also be clear, that's just the number of people who are diagnosed. So it's not including the people that haven't yet been able to access a diagnosis for various reasons because of health, inequality because they don't even recognize the symptoms in themselves because of stigma, any number of reasons. So if you want to understand OCDs and more, you basically have to understand as a starting point how it is described in the DSM 5. So the DSM is basically the reference point for all mental health or brain related conditions. OCD being one of those. And OCD is
我们也要明确，这仅仅是已被诊断的人数。所以它不包括那些由于种种原因（例如健康不平等、由于污名化而甚至没有在自己身上识别出症状、或任何其他原因）尚未能够获得诊断的人。所以，如果你想更多地了解强迫症，你基本上必须将它在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5）中的描述作为起点。因此，DSM基本上是所有心理健康或大脑相关状况的参考标准。强迫症就是其中之一。强迫症在
characterized in this book by two main components, obsessions and compulsions. You have to have both to have a diagnosis of OCD. Let's break down these components. So obsessions, these unwanted, intrusive and often very distressing thoughts, images or urges that just pop into someone's head seemingly out of nowhere. They are persistent. They typically cause a lot of anxiety and distress and they are frequent. They're frequent visitors in our minds. Here's the key point. These aren't just excessive worries about real life problems. If you are going broke and you are worried about money, you are obviously going to be thinking about money all the time because it is a present day issue for you that is very, very stressful. That doesn't make it an obsession
这本书中被两个主要部分所定义：强迫观念（obsessions）和强迫行为（compulsions）。要确诊强迫症，这两者缺一不可。让我们来剖析这些组成部分。首先是强迫观念，这些是不想要的、侵入性的、而且往往是非常令人痛苦的想法、图像或冲动，它们似乎毫无预兆地突然闯入某人的脑海。它们是持续存在的。它们通常会引起大量的焦虑和痛苦，而且它们很频繁。它们是我们心中的常客。关键点来了。这些不仅仅是对现实生活中问题的过度担忧。如果你正面临破产并且担心金钱，你显然会一直想着钱，因为这是你当前面临的一个非常非常压力山大的问题。但这并不能让它成为一个强迫观念
in OCD terms. Obsessions as a part of OCD are very different. They're what we call ego dystonic, meaning they clash with a person's true values, realities, beliefs, desires. They also are not always particularly relevant to what that individual is experiencing in that moment. So, for example, you may have intrusive thoughts about hurting someone, even though you're not hurting someone at that point. You can have intrusive thoughts that you're a bad person, even though, you know,
用强迫症的术语来说。作为强迫症一部分的强迫观念是非常不同的。它们被称为“自我异质性”（ego dystonic），这意味着它们与一个人的真实价值观、现实、信念、欲望相冲突。它们也并非总是与该个体在那一刻所经历的事情特别相关。例如，你可能会有关于伤害某人的侵入性想法，尽管你当时并没有伤害任何人。你可能会有自己是个坏人的侵入性想法，尽管你知道，
that doesn't match reality. You're not a bad person. You can have intrusive thoughts about the meaning of life that go against your beliefs about your purpose here. You can have false beliefs that someone in your family may be ill or that you may get ill that are totally unreasonable when we actually pair them up with reality, but which your brain thinks are 100% factual, true information. It's the fact that these thoughts are so counter to who we are, what's going on
这与现实不符。你不是个坏人。你可能会有关于生命意义的侵入性想法，这些想法违背了你对自己在这里的目的的信念。你可能会有错误的信念，认为你家里的某个人可能生病了或者你可能会生病，当我们把它们与现实进行比对时，这些想法是完全不合理的，但你的大脑却认为它们是100%的事实、真实的信息。正是因为这些想法与我们是谁、我们生活中正在发生的事情、我们希望如何看待自己是如此背道而驰，
in our lives, how we wish to see ourselves, that they cause so much fear and such intense anxiety or stress at times. Here's the other crucial thing. We can't help it. Of course, you know, if your life is falling apart, if your world is crumbling, like you're going to be anxious about what's happening in your environment and your circumstances, but with obsessive thoughts, they just come out of nowhere. There's no, typically, there's no like real reason. reason that they're there, they just are. How I'd like to explain it is that these thoughts are kind of like a smoke alarm going off in your head, and no matter how many times you push the button, it won't turn off. So you just have this alarm going on and on and on. Someone without OCD can easily turn off the button,
所以它们才会带来如此多的恐惧，有时还会引发如此强烈焦虑或压力。这里还有另一个至关重要的事。我们对此无能为力。当然，你知道，如果你的生活正在分崩离析，如果你的世界正在瓦解，你会对你环境和处境中发生的事情感到焦虑，但对于强迫性想法，它们就是凭空出现的。通常没有、也没有什么真正的理由。原因就是它们在那里，它们就是存在。我喜欢解释的方式是，这些想法有点像你脑海中响起的火灾报警器，无论你按多少次按钮，它都不会关掉。所以你就会有这个警报一直响个不停。没有强迫症的人可以轻易地关掉按钮，
but if you have OCD, you can't. So that's the first component, these obsessions. Then we have compulsions. These are the repetitive behaviours or mental acts that an individual feels driven kind of to perform in response to the obsessive thought. So you think something that's scary, you think something that's causing you panic, you think something that feels terrible in your body. And so the only way to stop that thought is to go and do a repetitive behavior,
但如果你有强迫症，你就关不掉。这就是第一个组成部分，这些强迫观念。接下来是强迫行为。这些是个人为了回应强迫观念而感到被迫去执行的重复行为或心理动作。所以你脑海中浮现了一些可怕的事情，你想到了让你恐慌的事情，你想到了在身体里感觉糟糕透顶的事情。所以制止这种想法的唯一方法就是去执行一种重复的行为，
to perform a compulsion that makes that thought feel less sharp. The goal of the compulsion is to prevent or reduce the feeling of distress that is caused by the obsession, or it's kind of this weird thing that we do that we think is going to stop something terrible from happening. We think that it's like protective. Either way, we kind of do see it as a good thing that we are doing these and that we are performing these compulsions because they are somehow neutralizing a threat or somehow saving us. You know, for example, you may have this fear that something's going to happen to your family, if you flick a light switch on and off 12 times, arbitrary number, well, then it's not going to
去执行一种强迫行为，让那种想法感觉不那么尖锐。强迫行为的目标是防止或减少由强迫观念引起的痛苦感，或者这是我们做的一种奇怪的事情，我们认为它能阻止糟糕的事情发生。我们认为这具有保护作用。无论哪种方式，我们确实认为做这些事情、执行这些强迫行为是件好事，因为它们在某种程度上中和了威胁，或者在某种程度上拯救了我们。你知道，例如，你可能会有一种恐惧，担心如果你的电灯开关不按12次（一个随意的数字），就会有什么事情发生到你的家人身上，嗯，那么它就不会
happen. How could you not do that? If you genuinely think that your family will perish in a car accident, if you don't flick the light switch on 12 times exactly, like, of course you're going to do that. Of course you're going to perform the compulsion. It's the only thing that in your mind is preventing this terrible thing from happening. It's the only thing that is cooling off the obsessive thought. It's not about pleasure. It's not about avoiding reality. It's about escaping the terror of the thought in your mind. It's about escaping what you think is going to happen if you don't address this thought with this compulsion. Just to nail this home, think about it like this. An obsession is screaming at you. Something terrible is going to happen if you don't do X. And the compulsion is the
发生。你怎么可能不那样做呢？如果你真心觉得如果不正好拨动电灯开关12次，你的家人就会在车祸中丧生，那你当然会那样做。你当然会去执行这种强迫行为。在你的脑海里，这是防止这件可怕的事情发生的唯一办法。这是平息强迫观念的唯一办法。这与快乐无关，也不是为了逃避现实。这是为了摆脱你脑海中对那种想法的恐惧。这是为了逃避如果你不用这种强迫行为来应对这个想法，你认为将会发生的事情。为了强调这一点，可以这样想：强迫观念对你大喊大叫，如果你不去做X，就会发生可怕的事情。
desperate, often illogical attempt to silence that scream and avert the perceived disaster by performing X. And both of these components, like I said before, are essential. There is actually something called purely obsessional OCD. They call it pure OCD, where the obsession is obviously the distressing thought, but the compulsion is just to think about that distressing thought more. And sometimes people can look at that and think, well, that's not OCD, there's no compulsion. this person isn't acting in a certain way to prevent the negative distressing thought. It is still OCD because the act of thinking is actually the compulsion. You can understand how freaking frustrating that can be, but in some ways it is soothing. Thinking about something constantly
绝望的、通常是不合逻辑的试图通过执行X来压制那种尖叫并避免感知到的灾难的行为。而且正如我之前所说，这两个组成部分都是必不可少的。实际上有一种叫做纯粹强迫型强迫症（OCD）的东西。他们称之为纯强迫症，在这种强迫症中，强迫观念显然是令人痛苦的想法，但强迫行为仅仅是更多地去思考那个令人痛苦的想法。有时人们看到这一点会想，嗯，这可不是强迫症，这里没有强迫行为，这个人并没有以某种方式行事来防止消极痛苦的想法。但这仍然是强迫症，因为思考的行为实际上就是强迫行为。你可以理解这有多么令人沮丧，但在某种程度上它也是一种安慰。不断地思考某事
over and over again until it feels safe is actually in some ways a form of OCD. It's a way that we try and try to turn the smoke alarm off. And that brings us to the OCD cycle, which is really what defines this disorder. So the OCD cycle starts with an intrusive thought. Now, here's a crucial piece of understanding that we can't miss out on. Intrusive thoughts are actually really common. Around 80 to 90% of the general population experiences intrusive thoughts on a regular basis. That's why intrusive thoughts alone are not enough to be diagnosed with OCD. Intrusive thoughts are basically just like random, unwanted, bizarre things, sometimes disturbing that just like pop into your head. You know,
一遍又一遍，直到感觉安全，在某种程度上实际上也是强迫症的一种形式。这是我们试图关掉烟雾警报器的一种方式。这就把我们带到了强迫症循环，这才是这个障碍的真正定义。所以强迫症循环始于闯入性思维。现在，这里有一个我们不能错过的关键理解。闯入性思维其实非常普遍。大约80%到90%的普通人群经常经历闯入性思维。这就是为什么仅仅有闯入性思维还不足以被诊断为强迫症。闯入性思维基本上就像随机的、不需要的、奇怪的东西，有时甚至是不安的东西，就像突然闯入你的脑海。你知道的，
you're the best example, you're standing on the train platform and you're like, what if I just jumped? Or you're driving your car and you're like, what if I just crash my car? You're holding a baby. You're like, you just have this image of yourself like throwing the baby on the ground and then it disappears. You know, for most people, those thoughts are quickly dismissed. You might think, that's really weird. Obviously, I'm not going to do that. Like, that's crazy. And your brain just filters it out, recognizes it as just like a random brain blip. But for someone with OCD, those thoughts don't just pass by. They become sticky. Their brain doesn't filter it out. It flags it as really important, really important information. It flags those thoughts as dangerous. It flags those thoughts
你是最好的例子，你站在火车站台上，心想：如果我跳下去会怎么样？或者你开着车心想：如果我把车撞了会怎么样？你抱着一个婴儿，然后你脑海中突然浮现出自己把婴儿扔到地上的画面，然后它就消失了。你知道，对大多数人来说，这些想法很快就被驳回了。你可能会想，这太奇怪了。显然我不会那么做，这太疯狂了。然后你的大脑就会把它过滤掉，认为这只是大脑中随机的一个小故障。但对于患有强迫症的人来说，这些想法不会轻易过去。它们变得粘稠。他们的大脑不会将其过滤掉。它将其标记为非常重要、非常重要的信息。它将这些想法标记为危险。它将这些想法
as something that they have to pay attention to. And so when that thought enters, the part of our brain that filters out thoughts that are useful in those that aren't grabs onto it and holds onto it tight. So like let's say you are spending time with your family and for like a split second you think, what if I end up hurting my family member? What if I stab my family? Something bizarre like that. Someone without OCD might think, like think that and be like, that is so weird that I just thought that. What a random thought. What a horrible thought. I'd obviously never do that. And you can refocus. For someone with OCD, though, instead of just being able to dismiss it, the brain immediately
标记为他们必须注意的事情。因此，当这个想法进入时，我们大脑中负责过滤有用和无用想法的部分就会抓住它并紧紧不放。所以，假设你正在和家人在一起，在一瞬间你想：如果我最终伤害了我的家人会怎么样？如果我捅了我的家人会怎么样？诸如此类的奇怪事情。没有强迫症的人可能会这样想，然后觉得：我刚才竟然会有这种想法，真是太奇怪了。多么随机的想法啊。多么可怕的想法。我显然永远不会那样做。然后你就可以重新集中注意力。然而，对于强迫症患者来说，大脑不仅不能将其驳回，反而会立即
interprets this thought as highly significant and threatening, thinking, oh my God, but why did I think that? Obviously, if I thought that, it means some part of me really wants to do that. And if some part of me really wants to do that, that I'm a monster. And if I'm a monster, I shouldn't be around my family. Because if I'm having those thoughts and obviously I'm going to act on them, you can see how this creates a lot of anxiety, a lot of dread. Individuals with OCD often have an inflated sense of responsibility. Inflated responsibility basically means that they have this exaggerated belief
将这个想法解释为具有高度重大意义和威胁性，心想：天哪，我为什么会有这种想法？显然，如果我有这种想法，就意味着我内心某处真的很想这么做。如果我内心某处真的很想这么做，那我就是一个怪物。如果我是个怪物，我就不应该和家人在一起。因为如果我有这些想法，我显然会付诸行动。你可以看出这会产生多少焦虑和恐惧。强迫症患者通常具有膨胀的责任感。膨胀的责任感基本上意味着他们有一种夸大的信念
that they as individuals have the power to cause or prevent negative outcomes, even when objectively they don't. This feeling of being excessively responsible for preventing bad things from happening, even if it sounds delusional to people who don't have OCD, what it means is that the thoughts that they're having around family members being hurt, them hurting family members, terrible things happening, really difficult to shake. But this is where the compulsion comes in. The compulsion is introduced as this behavior that can make all of that go away.
即他们作为个人有能力引发或阻止负面结果，即使在客观上他们并没有这种能力。这种对阻止坏事发生承担过多责任的感觉，即使对没有强迫症的人来说听起来像是一种妄想，但这意味着他们围绕家人受伤、自己伤害家人以及发生可怕事情的想法，真的很难摆脱。但强迫行为就是在这个时候切入的。强迫行为作为一种能够让这一切消失的行为被引入。
There is some behavior they believe they can do, that will shield them from the bad thing happening, that will shield the people they love from bad things happening. And so, of course, they're going to do it. They're going to wash their hands as many times as they need. They're going to ask for reassurance until the cows come home. They're going to check every single lock 12 times because that's how many times they need to do it to ensure that they haven't missed anything.
有一种他们认为自己可以做出的行为，能够保护他们免受坏事的侵害，能够保护他们所爱的人免受坏事的侵害。所以，他们当然会这么做。他们会尽可能多次地洗手。他们会不断寻求安慰，直到天荒地老。他们会把每一个锁检查12次，因为这就是他们需要检查的次数，以确保他们没有遗漏任何东西。
You can kind of see where this is going. One of my compulsions when I was a child, and again, I don't know how anyone freaking missed this. But I guess I never told anyone. But when I was a kid, every single night before I went to bed, I would pray and I would have to pray for exactly one minute and 45 seconds. And my prayer would have to be very, very specific. I would have to mention every single member of my family. I'd have to say all of these certain things.
你大概能猜到这会走向何方。我小时候的强迫行为之一——话说回来，我真不知道怎么会有人漏掉这个。但我猜我从来没告诉过任何人。但当我还是个孩子的时候，每天晚上睡觉前我都会祈祷，而且我必须祈祷整整1分钟45秒。我的祈祷必须非常非常具体。我必须提到我家庭的每一个成员。我必须说出所有这些特定的事情。
I'd have to thank God for five different things every single night, otherwise something bad was going to happen. My family was not religious. At this stage, I had never stepped foot in a church. I think I started doing this when I was like four. I had, like I had no, I didn't go to a religious school. I lived in like a part of Australia where, you know, religion wasn't really a huge thing. But I'd gotten in my mind that, you know, if I didn't do this, people would be hurt. Here's the cruel irony of that, though.
我必须每天晚上感谢上帝五件不同的事情，否则就会有坏事发生。我的家人并不信教。在这个阶段，我从未踏入过教堂。我想我大概四岁时就开始这么做了。我当时根本没有，我没有上过宗教学校。我住在澳大利亚的一个地方，你知道的，宗教并不是一件大事。但我的脑海里认定，你知道，如果我不这样做，人们就会受伤。然而，这里面有一个残酷的讽刺。
Performing the compulsion only provides a very temporary brief sense of relief before the anxiety comes racing back. But this just momentary relief actually reinforces the compulsion. Of course, if you're so distressed by these thoughts, you're having any sense of calm is one that you are going to pursue. But what that means is that your brain learns, okay, when I have the scary thought that a family member is going to die, I'm going to get a disease, something terrible is going to happen. If I do X, the bad feeling goes away. Well, then of course I'm going to keep doing X. And this really strengthens the link between the obsession and the compulsion. making it more likely that the cycle will repeat the next time the obsession appears.
执行强迫行为只能提供非常短暂的缓解感，然后焦虑就会汹涌而回。但这仅仅是暂时的缓解，实际上却强化了强迫行为。当然，如果你被这些想法折磨得如此痛苦，任何平静感都是你将要追求的。但这意味着你的大脑学会了：好吧，当我产生家人会死去、我会得病、会有可怕的事情发生的恐惧想法时，如果我做了X，不好的感觉就会消失。好吧，那我当然会继续做X。这 realmente 加强了强迫观念和强迫行为之间的联系，使得下次强迫观念出现时，循环重复的可能性更大。
The child will continue to pray. The person will continue to wash their hands. They will continue to check the lock 12 times. And because the compulsion momentarily feels like it prevents the feared outcome, probably because the feared outcome was never going to happen anyway, you never get to test whether the fear was realistic in the first place. The cycle gets stronger, the anxiety returns, the compulsion becomes more rigid and frequent. I think something that's really key to highlight when talking about OCD is actually how vast this condition really is. Like we said at the beginning,
孩子会继续祈祷。这个人会继续洗手。他们会继续检查锁12次。而且因为强迫行为暂时让人觉得它阻止了可怕的结果（可能是因为可怕的结果本来就不会发生），你永远没有机会去检验这种恐惧在最初是否切合实际。循环变得更强，焦虑回归，强迫行为变得更加死板和频繁。我认为在讨论强迫症时，真正需要强调的一点实际上是这个病症的广泛程度。就像我们在开始时所说的那样，
it's not just tidiness. There are all these different categories of OCD symptoms that I think is really important that we know of. So we are going to take a short break here, but when we return, I want to talk through these very important categories and how they are very, very distinctive and different. stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
它不仅仅是爱整洁。强迫症症状还有所有这些不同的类别，我认为了解这些类别非常重要。所以我们要在这里稍事休息，但当我们回来时，我想讨论这些非常重要的类别，以及它们如何非常、非常独特和不同。请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中。我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
来审视那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是I-Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“回顾过去”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔参加的节目，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的瘾品。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crazy. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为疯狂的瘾品。我很乐意在节目中谈论瘾品，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论瘾品的第二集。所以我开始发现其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上桌面了。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。欢迎收听我的新播客“从艰难中学习”，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢和输的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客“从艰难中学习”中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开你免费的I-Heart Radio应用，搜索“从艰难中学习”并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后举行的家庭法庭听证会揭示了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你对某人篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试是一次。这需要一支网络侦探大军来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“爱情陷阱”。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So researchers and people in like the clinical mental health space often categorize
劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被大陪审团以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在I Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“爱情陷阱”播客。所以，研究人员和临床心理健康领域的人经常将
OCD symptoms into various common themes or dimensions just to kind of make it easier to label people and to choose what treatment would work best for them. I'm going to share some of these with you guys now. This is actually by no means an exhaustive list. it's just the most common ones. So the first is the classic, it's the most recognized type of OCD, contamination and cleaning. Obsessions to do with this might involve intense fears of germs, dirt, bodily fluids, chemicals, chemicals in your food, or even mental contamination, feeling dirty from a negative thought or an interaction.
强迫症症状分类为各种常见的主题或维度，只是为了更容易地给人们贴上标签，并选择最适合他们的治疗方法。我现在要和大家分享其中的一些。实际上，这绝不是一份详尽无遗的清单，而只是最常见的那些。所以第一种是经典的、最广为人知的强迫症类型，污染与清洁。与之相关的强迫观念可能包括对细菌、污垢、体液、化学物质、食物中的化学物质，甚至精神污染（因消极想法或互动而感觉自己变脏）的强烈恐惧。
The underlying fear is not of the dirt, not of the germs. it's of illness, it's of death, it's of moral impurity, it's of something being in your body that you can't control. Compulsions around this might involve excessive hand-washing, showering, cleaning objects, avoiding perceived contaminants or asking others to clean things because you trust the more, all driven by that desperate need to alleviate that fear. I actually read a really fascinating article about a group of people, well, they weren't really a group, but people, individually who would not get the COVID vaccine because they were so scared of, obviously, of having something in their body that they couldn't control. It's not that they thought the vaccine
潜在的恐惧不是对污垢的恐惧，也不是对细菌的恐惧。而是对疾病的恐惧，对死亡的恐惧，对道德不纯洁的恐惧，对体内有无法控制的东西的恐惧。围绕这一点的强迫行为可能包括过度洗手、洗澡、清洁物品、避开被视为污染物的东西，或者要求其他人清洁东西，因为你更信任他们，所有这些都是由减轻这种恐惧的绝望需求所驱动的。我实际上读过一篇非常fascinating的文章，关于一群人，好吧，他们其实不是一个群体，而是个人，他们不会去接种新冠疫苗，因为他们非常害怕体内有自己无法控制的东西。并不是说他们认为疫苗
was bad. It's not that they didn't even believe in vaccines. They were just so fearful of chemicals or things they didn't understand being in their body. And so you can see how this goes very, very deep and has a real societal impact. The next kind of category is, around symmetry, around symmetry, ordering and feeling that things need to be just right, perfectly aligned, balanced, exact. This fear can be rather vague, but it can also be really intense and really what it's coming down to is this sense that something bad might happen if the world doesn't have order and that there is an impending sense of doom or terror that will afflict the person if their environment is in ordered just so.
情况很糟。倒不是说他们不相信疫苗，而是他们太害怕化学物质或者他们不理解的东西进入体内。所以你可以看到，这种心态根深蒂固，并对社会产生了真实的冲击。下一个类别是关于对称性，追求对称、秩序，觉得事情必须恰到好处、完美对齐、平衡且准确。这种恐惧可能相当含糊，但也可以非常强烈，而归根结底，它是一种感觉：如果世界没有秩序，可能会有坏事发生；如果环境没有被整齐排列，当事人就会陷入一种迫在眉睫的厄运感或恐怖之中。
Compulsions around this might involve arranging objects repeatedly, repeating actions until they feel perfect. So reentering a doorway until it feels just right, because if it doesn't feel right, maybe that's a sign that something's off. Doing counting rituals is another one. The sheer like distress and fear comes from things feeling out of place and this like very unbearable internal tension that doesn't settle on its own. It needs to be settled by things in the environment or certain sensations.
围绕这方面的强迫行为可能包括反复排列物品，重复动作直到感觉完美。比如反复进出门口，直到感觉对了为止，因为如果感觉不对，可能就预示着有什么不对劲。做计数仪式是另一种表现。纯粹的痛苦和恐惧源于事情感觉不对劲，以及这种无法自行消散的、极其难耐的内部紧张感。它需要通过环境中的事物或某些感觉来平复。
Another really common dimension of OCD centers around harm and responsibility, something that we've kind of alluded to already in today's episode. This is where it can get quite dark and distressing for the individual. these obsessions often involve really terrifying fears of harming oneself, harming others, accidentally harming them, or being violent or aggressive towards people without really wanting to be. For example, a new parent might have a terrifying intrusive image in their brain of harming their child, even though they have absolutely no desire to do that. And that creates really immense guilt and shame.
强迫症的另一个非常普遍的维度围绕着伤害和责任，这我们在今天的节目中已经稍微提及过了。这也是对个人而言可能变得相当阴暗和痛苦的地方。这些强迫观念通常涉及非常可怕的恐惧：伤害自己、伤害他人、意外伤害他人，或者在并非真心想要的情况下对他人表现出暴力或攻击性。例如，新手父母脑海中可能会浮现出伤害孩子的可怕侵入性画面，尽管他们绝对没有这种愿望。这会产生巨大的内疚和羞耻感。
And some psychologists, some researchers have even suggested that it's the very fact that they know they won't do it and that it is so terrible that their brain feels like continuously drawn to it like a magnet. Like, wow, this thing is so intense and so dark. Well, we have to sit with this even longer just to really make sure. But in sitting with it, the lines kind of get blurry. You don't actually want to do it. That's something we really have to be clear of here. You don't want to hurt someone. You don't want to hurt yourself. But the fact that the thought is there is confusing to you because you think, well, why would I be thinking of it if I didn't want to do it? Compulsions to do with this involve extreme avoidance of sharp objects, of children, of certain people, but also constantly seeking reassurance that you haven't harmed anyone, constantly confessing, perceived. bad thoughts or just constantly mentally reviewing past events to check for any wrongdoing. You can see why this is sometimes confused with anxiety, right? This overthinking element, this rumination element, is something that OCD and anxiety have
一些心理学家、一些研究人员甚至提出，正因为他们知道自己不会这样做，而且这件事如此可怕，以至于他们的大脑就像磁铁一样不断被其吸引。心想：哇，这件事太强烈、太黑暗了。好吧，我们必须更长时间地去面对它，以真正确保万无一失。但在面对它的过程中，界限变得有些模糊了。你其实并不想这么做——这是我们在这里必须真正明确的一点。你不想伤害任何人。你不想伤害你自己。但这个想法的存在却让你感到困惑，因为你想：如果我不想做，我为什么会想到它？与此相关的强迫行为包括极度回避尖锐物品、儿童、特定人群，但也包括不断寻求没有伤害任何人的保证、不断坦白察觉到的坏想法，或者不断在脑海中回顾过去的事件来检查是否有任何不当行为。你可以明白为什么这有时会被与焦虑混淆了吧？这种过度思考的成分、这种反刍的成分，是强迫症和焦虑症
in common. There's also religious or moral OCD. This is sometimes referred to as scrupulosity. Scrupulosity? You know when you see a word written down? you've never like actually said it before. Like scrupulosity. Yeah. Basically, it involves obsessions and compulsions centered around religious, moral or ethical beliefs. I was actually listening to a podcast about this the other day that was interviewing priests, new priests who were dealing with
共同拥有的特点。还有宗教或道德强迫症。这有时被称为谨小慎微症（scrupulosity）。谨小慎微症？你知道当你看到一个写下来的词时……你以前从来没有真正说出口过，比如“scrupulosity”。是的。基本上，它涉及以宗教、道德或伦理信仰为中心的强迫观念和强迫行为。我前几天其实听了一个关于这方面的播客，采访了一些牧师，新牧师们正在处理
these people who just like wouldn't stop calling them, members of their church, who would confess every single little thing that they'd done even when it wasn't bad. And the priests were having to deal with this fact that they were like, this one guy was like, oh, you know, I went to vacuum my carpet and I missed a bit. And is God going to be mad at me about that? And the priest had to be like, oh, no. And this woman who was like, oh, you know, I cooked dinner for my husband, but I was going to cook something else. But what if he wanted the other thing, more than he wanted the thing that I gave him? I've displeased him. I'm evil. Does this mean I'm going to hell? And the priest had to be like, no. It's these fears of sinning.
这些人就是不停地打电话给他们，他们教会的成员，哪怕事情并不糟糕，他们也会坦白自己做的每一件小事。牧师们不得不应对这种状况，他们就像……有个家伙说：“噢，你知道，我去用吸尘器吸地毯，漏了一小块。上帝会为此生我的气吗？”牧师不得不说：“噢，不会的。”还有一个女人说：“噢，你知道，我给我丈夫做晚饭，但我本来想做别的。但如果他更想要别的东西，而不是我给他的这个呢？我惹他生气了。我是个恶魔。这是否意味着我要下地狱？”牧师不得不说：“不会的。”这就是对犯罪的恐惧、
of being immoral, and really it's a deeper fear of divine punishment of hell, of eternal damnation. So these people might pray excessively, repeat religious rituals, obviously seek constant forgiveness from members of the church, or really avoid situations that they think could lead to immoral thoughts. The final one I want to mention is relationship OCD. I feel like some of you probably saw this coming. We actually have an entire episode on this from earlier this year with an expert. But all she does is talk about relationship OCD. She is amazing.
对不道德的恐惧，而实际上它是对神圣惩罚、对地狱、对永恒诅咒的更深层恐惧。所以这些人可能会过度祈祷、重复宗教仪式，显然会不断寻求教会成员的原谅，或者极力避免他们认为会导致不道德想法的情境。我想提到的最后一个是关系强迫症。我觉得你们中的一些人可能已经预料到了。今年早些时候，我们其实有一整期节目专门邀请了一位专家来探讨这个话题。她所做的一切就是谈论关系强迫症。她太棒了。
She knows every single dimension on this. If this is something that you feel particularly drawn to understanding more, you can go and listen to that episode. But relationship OCD really involves intrusive doubts and obsessions about your romantic or close personal relationships. These obsessions might really focus on a partner's flaws, the rightness of the relationship. any doubts you have in your mind about how much you love them, about your attraction to them, whether other people feel this way about their partner, whether your relationship is wrong, whether it's right, whether you're doing the right things. The core fear here is often around making the wrong decision, around hurting someone
她对这方面的每一个维度都了如指掌。如果你觉得特别想深入了解这一点，你可以去听听那一期节目。但关系强迫症确实涉及对你的浪漫关系或亲密个人关系的侵入性怀疑和强迫观念。这些强迫观念可能真正集中在伴侣的缺点、关系的正确性上，集中在你脑海中关于你有多爱他们、你对他们的吸引力、其他人是否也这样看待他们的伴侣、你的关系是否错误、是否正确、你做的事情是否正确的任何怀疑上。这里的核心恐惧通常围绕着做出错误的决定、通过不够爱他们而伤害并离开他们、浪费你的时间、浪费他们的时间。
by not loving them enough and leaving them, of wasting your time, of wasting their time. compulsions really often include excessive comparison, constantly comparing your relationship to others, mentally reviewing the relationship history, constantly seeking reassurance about the relationship's validity, constantly asking other people about their relationship, what was their timeline, how were they feeling at this point in their relationship to kind of compare your own? this intense doubt and fear can really damage almost every single relationship that you're in. Even the ones that are almost perfect. Even the ones that there is absolutely nothing wrong,
强迫行为通常包括过度比较，不断将你的关系与他人进行比较，在脑海中回顾关系历史，不断寻求关于关系有效性的保证，不断询问其他人关于他们关系的情况、他们的时间线是什么样的、他们在关系的这个阶段有什么感觉，以此来比较你自己的感觉……这种强烈的怀疑和恐惧真的会损害你几乎身处的每一段关系。甚至是那些几乎完美的、甚至绝对没有任何问题的关系。
if you look for something wrong in a relationship, you will find it. You will absolutely find it because no relationship is perfect, right? So if you have OCD and your brain is real hell bent on hunting for that, hunting for that thing that's wrong, you are going to find at least something that you can cling on to. So with these categories, it might be that someone has just one type of OCD, but it is also possible for OCD to change and attach itself onto different themes because the core underlying mechanism is the same.
如果你在一段关系中寻找问题，你就会找到它。你绝对会找到它，因为没有任何关系是完美的，对吧？所以，如果你患有强迫症，而你的大脑真的铁了心要寻找那个问题、寻找那个出错的地方，你至少会找到一些你可以死死抓住的东西。因此，对于这些类别来说，可能有人只患有一种类型的强迫症，但强迫症也有可能会改变并依附于不同的主题，因为核心的底层机制是相同的。
It just might have a different expression. The sheer variety of themes as well means that true people with OCD might present completely differently, yet they will both be battling the same underlying mechanisms of intrusive thoughts and compulsive responses. The issue that comes with this is that sometimes they don't get the proper treatment or diagnosis because people don't understand where OCD came from, even some professionals, even some people who are meant to specialize in mental health disorders because this disorder is so varied, they just might not recognize a new permutation. So before we get into that part of this story and that part of why this happens, let's actually talk about what
它可能只是有不同的表现形式。主题的纯粹多样性也意味着，真正的强迫症患者可能会表现得完全不同，然而他们都在与侵入性思维和强迫性反应的相同底层机制做斗争。随之而来的问题是，有时他们无法获得正确的治疗或诊断，因为人们不理解强迫症从何而来，甚至连一些专业人士、一些本该专攻心理健康障碍的人也是如此。由于这种障碍如此多变，他们可能无法识别出一种新的变体。因此，在我们进入故事的那一部分以及为什么会发生这种情况的那一部分之前，让我们先来谈谈是什么
causes OCD. Where does this come from? Obviously, our brains play a very significant, if not the most important role, hence why this is called a mental health disorder, but it's not that you have a broken brain. By no means it's that. It's that there are just specific differences in how certain brain circuits function versus. is how they function in someone else. And these differences, which no one can really control, no one's in charge of, they do predispose someone to developing OCD compared to someone else, and they contribute to profound feelings of being trapped by thoughts and compulsions. The crucial structure we need to understand, and bear with me, it's a long name,
导致了强迫症。这究竟是从哪里来的？显然，我们的大脑发挥了非常重要、甚至是最重要的作用，这也是为什么这被称为心理健康障碍，但这并不是说你的大脑坏了。绝不是这样。而是某些大脑回路的功能运作方式与在其他人身上的运作方式存在特定的差异。这些没有人能真正控制、没有人能主导的差异，确实会使某人比其他人更容易倾向于发展出强迫症，它们也会导致一种被思想和强迫行为深深困住的强烈感觉。我们需要了解的关键结构是——请耐心听我说，这是一个很长的名字，
but it's called the corticostriato thalamocortical loop. CSTC loop. I know. I know you're probably thinking, what the heck is that? That sounds like you just made that up. I didn't. It's a real thing. It's a real structure. It's basically a brain circuit that acts like, the best way I can describe it is like it's a busy highway in your brain for information and it connects all these areas that are involved in decision making, error detection, habit formation, reassurance checking, observation, all these things. It's a very important structure. And when part of this highway doesn't work or it's closed down, the loop obviously can't function, and that is where a disorder like OCD emerges. So the first area that we need to understand as part of this loop is the part that's
但它被称为皮质纹状体丘脑皮质环路（CSTC环路）。CSTC环路。我知道。我知道你可能在想，那到底是什么鬼？听起来像刚编出来的一样。我没有编。这是真实存在的。这是一个真实的结构。它基本上是一个大脑回路，其作用就像……我能形容的最好方式就是，它就像你大脑中一条繁忙的信息高速公路，它连接着所有参与决策、错误检测、习惯形成、保证检查、观察等方面的区域。这是一个非常重要的结构。当这条高速公路的一部分不工作或关闭时，环路显然就无法正常运转，像强迫症这样的障碍就是从这里产生的。因此，作为该环路的一部分，我们需要理解的第一个区域是负责
responsible for decision making. It's called the orbital frontal cortex. In OCD, research has shown that that part of the cortex, I should say, is hyperactive. It's like an overly sensitive alarm bell, constantly flagging thoughts as critical threats, feeding that fear that something terrible is going to happen even when it's not. The way I describe it as like a really anxious parent who sees everything as something that's going to harm their child. So that is the first part of the brain that's quite hyperactive or something's going wrong. Second area is the area responsible for error detection. It's called the anterior cingulate cortex. It's located very deep inside the brain, when it's not working right, it keeps, again, sending the something is wrong
决策的部分。它被称为眶额皮层。在强迫症中，研究表明那部分皮层（我应该这么说）处于过度活跃状态。它就像一个过于敏感的警报铃，不断将思想标记为严重威胁，并助长这样一种恐惧：即使在并非如此的时候，可怕的事情也会发生。我将其描述为就像一个极其焦虑的父母，把一切都看作是会伤害自己孩子的事物。所以，那是大脑中相当过度活跃或出现某种问题的第一个部分。第二个区域是负责错误检测的区域。它被称为前扣带皮层。它位于大脑的非常深处，当它运作不正常时，它会再次不断发送“有情况”
signals. So that orbital frontal part of your brain is saying that it's wrong, saying that something is wrong. And then the second part of your brain is interpreting that and sending these alarm bells that it doesn't really need to. That is what's creating this fear response or this distress that you can't turn off. And then we also have the basal ganglia, which is responsible for habit formation. So errors or issues with this area, mean that you are going to start performing these compulsive ritualistic actions and falsely associating those actions with a positive outcome. So, you know, you think something bad's going to happen.
的信号。所以你大脑的那部分眶额叶在说出问题了，说有什么不对劲。然后你大脑的第二部分在解读这一点，并拉响它其实并不真正需要的警报铃。这就是产生这种无法关闭的恐惧反应或痛苦的原因。然后我们还有负责习惯形成的基底神经节。因此，该区域的错误或问题意味着你将开始执行这些强迫性的仪式化动作，并错误地将这些动作与积极的结果联系起来。所以，你知道，你认为会有坏事发生。
You perform an action. The bad thing doesn't happen. You know, that logically you can kind of see that, well, duh, like maybe the bad thing wasn't going to happen anyways. But this part of your brain thinks, oh, no, like actually this action has been reinforced by something bad not happening. Obviously, I saved myself. Obviously, I did something right. This is the cure. So basically when this part isn't working, it makes it really hard to stop performing your repetitive action in response to an unwanted thought. So you can kind of see when the communication
你执行了一个动作。坏事没有发生。你知道，从逻辑上讲，你可以看出，嗨，就像坏事无论如何可能也不会发生一样。但你大脑的这部分却认为：“哦，不，实际上这个动作是因为没有坏事发生而得到了强化。显然，我拯救了自己。显然，我做对了什么。这就是解药。”所以基本上，当这部分不工作时，它会让人很难停止针对不想要的念头去执行重复的动作。因此，你可以看出，当这些大脑区域之间的沟通
between these brain areas is a little bit off. This is what creates that loop that we were describing before. Basically, what I'm trying to say is it's not you. It's not you. It's a your brain. So let's talk about when these symptoms first begin to emerge. So OCD can actually emerge at any age. Kind of scary when you think about it, but there are two primary ages where it is most likely to begin or occur or first be noticed, and that is between the ages of 9 to 11, and then again around 20 to 21 years of age. If we think about those years, they are really significant periods in our lives. The first is basically when puberty begins and then the second when we reach our 20s is where we have this second huge shift in our lives in terms of gaining independence,
有点失常时，这就是我们之前描述的那种环路的成因。基本上，我想说的是，这不是你的问题。不是你的问题。是大脑的问题。那么，让我们来谈谈这些症状何时开始显现。事实上，强迫症可以在任何年龄发作。仔细想想有点吓人，但它最可能开始、发生或首次被注意到的主要有两个年龄段，那就是9到11岁之间，然后是20到21岁左右。如果我们回想一下这些岁数，它们确实是我们生命中非常重要的时期。第一个基本上是青春期开始的时候，第二个当我们进入20多岁时，我们在获得独立、
maybe moving away from home, forming new relationships, this added sense of responsibility, which we know people with OCD really struggle with. It's even what some people call second puberty. Those first two years of your 20s, like so much is changing. There are monumental shifts. And this can you know, cause a massive impact on our stress levels and our mental health. So some researchers will say that it's not that OCD is more likely to occur. It's not that these time periods are significant, is probably what I should say. It's not that these periods or these years are special in any way. Like that number doesn't mean anything is actually what's happening developmentally. And it's actually what's happening in terms of life stress. So much is changing during those periods of our life. It's the
也许搬离家、建立新关系、增加责任感（我们知道患有强迫症的人对此深感挣扎）等方面迎来了生活中的第二次巨大转变。这也是有些人所说的“第二次青春期”。在你20多岁的前两年里，有太多的事物在改变。这是决定性的转变。这（你知道的）会对我们的压力水平和心理健康产生巨大的影响。因此，一些研究人员会说，并不是强迫症更有可能发生。我应该说，并不是这些时间段意义重大，并不是说这些时期或这些年有什么特别之处。其实从发育角度来看，那个数字没有任何意义。而真正发生的是生活压力方面的变化。在我们生命的那些时期，有太多事情在改变。正是
change and it's the stress that is triggering OCD. Another really critical time when people are more likely to be diagnosed with OCD is right after a child has been born, right after they've given birth. Because obviously that's like a, that's a huge life change. Your whole like center of orbit shifts to be that child. And often when someone develops OCD around this period in their life, the symptoms often often focus around the child, around accidentally, accidentally harming the child, contaminating the child in some way. So it is really tied to the context. And it really does
这种变化和压力在引发强迫症。另一个人们更有可能被诊断出患有强迫症的关键时期，是孩子出生后不久，也就是刚刚分娩后。因为很显然，那是一场巨大的生活巨变。你的整个生活中心都转移到了那个孩子身上。通常，当有人在人生的这个阶段患上强迫症时，症状往往集中在孩子身上，比如不小心、意外地伤害孩子，或者以某种方式污染孩子。所以它确实与所处的情境紧密相连。它确实也
highlight how stressful, significant life changes can act as a trigger, especially if you already have a biological predisposition, especially if a family member, a parent, a sibling has OCD. It's likely that you have some of the same elements of your DNA, blueprint that make you more predisposed. Doesn't mean that it's going to happen. Doesn't mean that you are determined to develop OCD. It just means that it may be more likely and that you are more susceptible to triggers. Another explanation also comes down to the role of serotonin. A lot of people think of serotonin as purely like the happy chemical alongside dopamine, but we do know that they're really involved more deeply in motivation and in
凸显了压力巨大、意义重大的生活变化如何能够充当诱因，特别是如果你已经有了生物学上的易感性，特别是如果家庭成员、父母、兄弟姐妹患有强迫症的话。你很可能拥有某些相同的DNA蓝图元素，这使你更具易感性。这并不意味着它一定会发生。并不意味着你注定会患上强迫症。这只是意味着它可能更有可能发生，而且你对诱因更加敏感。另一种解释也归结为血清素的作用。很多人认为血清素与多巴胺一样纯粹是快乐化学物质，但我们确实知道它们更深地参与到动机和
emotional regulation, being able to have a feeling, have a thought, and not invest in it entirely. So people who are more predisposed to developing OCD might also have some differences in terms of how their brain processes, interprets, stores, releases serotonin, which is why if you go to a doctor, if you go to a psychiatrist, one of the first things that they will often offer you as a solution is SSRI's selective serotonin re-uptake inhibitors. Complicated name basically just means that there's more serotonin in your brain for your neurons and your synapses to use. So you are less likely to suffer from a deficit in that neurotransmitter that could
情绪调节中，即能够产生一种感觉、产生一个想法，而不会完全陷入其中。因此，更倾向于发展出强迫症的人，在大脑处理、解释、储存、释放血清素的方式上也可能存在一些差异，这就是为什么如果你去看医生、去看精神科医生，他们通常会提供给你的首要解决方案之一就是SSRIs（选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂）。这个复杂的名称基本上意味着你大脑中有更多的血清素可供神经元和突触使用。因此，你不太可能患上那种可能导致强迫症症状的神经递质赤字。
contribute to OCD symptoms. Actually, just recently a really big paper came out talking about whether SSRIs are actually even effective at all. I'm not even going to get into it because I don't even think that I have formed my own opinion about the research, but it's something on the horizon. People are kind of starting to rethink this purely biological approach to mental health. That aside, basically what we want to understand is that OCD really isn't just caused by one thing. It is a complex interplay of various factors, kind of like a perfect storm of psychological vulnerabilities or patterns to do with biology,
其实就在最近，有一篇非常大的论文发表，探讨SSRIs是否真的有效。我甚至不想深入探讨它，因为我甚至不认为我已经对这项研究形成了自己的看法，但这是即将到来的一大趋势。人们开始重新思考这种纯粹的生物学心理健康方法。撇开这不谈，基本上我们想要理解的是，强迫症真的不仅仅是由一件事引起的。它是各种因素错综复杂的相互作用，有点像心理脆弱性或与生物学、
predisposition, environmental triggers that all kind of come together and mean that someone ends up in this terrible obsessive compulsive loop. Okay, we're going to take another short break, but when we return, I want to talk about the light at the end of the tunnel, I guess, some of the treatment options, some of the ways that we can better understand our OCD and also just advocate for ourselves in a system that doesn't really understand it. So stay with us. We will be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people
易感性、环境诱因相关的模式的一场完美风暴，所有这些结合在一起，意味着某人最终陷入了这个可怕的强迫观念-强迫行为的循环中。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我想谈谈隧道尽头的曙光，我想是一些治疗选择，一些能够更好地理解我们的强迫症、并在一个并不真正理解它的系统中为自己发声的方法。所以请继续收听我们节目。我们在短暂的休息后马上回来。2%。这就是
who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、
researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek.
经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-O-Percent”。你还记得黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英国（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这段时期的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为犯罪。还有可卡因。我随时都可以谈论可卡因，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
欢迎来到我的新播客《用最难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我指的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
在我的新播客《用最难的方式学习》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了他故事中前后矛盾的惊人之处。这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini.
你在某人的测试中篡改了这特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试了一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大队才能破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格，同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，
is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So as my story kind of explained at the very beginning, getting an accurate OCD diagnosis isn't always straightforward. In fact, significant delays are incredibly common. You know, I was looking into this. I was like, I cannot be the only one who has experienced this.
这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以正如我的故事在一开始所解释的那样，获得准确的强迫症诊断并不总是那么简单的。事实上，严重的延迟诊断极其普遍。你知道，我一直在调查这件事。我当时想：我绝对不可能是唯一一个经历过这种事的人。
And it's not like I'm blaming anyone or saying, you know, yeah, I'm not blaming anyone. or saying, you know, yeah, I'm not blaming anyone. I'm not blaming my family. I'm not blaming previous mental health professionals. I think it's just because of like the inherent invisibility of many symptoms, the fact that sometimes people don't see the nuances between symptoms that anxiety and OCD are different because of like, there's like a 5% difference, but that 5% means everything. And also the shame, the fact that sometimes a lot of the compulsions or the obsessions are things we don't really. really want to admit, and that leads to more severe symptoms and more prolonged suffering.
这并不是说我在责怪任何人，或者说，你知道，是的，我没有责怪任何人。或者说，你知道，是的，我没有责怪任何人。我没有责怪我的家人。我没有责怪之前的心理健康专业人士。我想这只是因为许多症状本身具有隐蔽性，有时人们看不到症状之间的细微差别——焦虑和强迫症之所以不同，是因为它们之间存在大约5%的差异，但那5%意味着一切。还有羞耻感，事实上，有时许多强迫行为或强迫观念是我们真正不愿意承认的事情，这导致了更严重的症状和更长时间的痛苦。
Like I said, I was researching this. I found this study from 2021 from the University of Leipzig, which actually found that the average time between the age that symptoms appear and the age that people get diagnosed for OCD is on average 13 years, 13 years over a decade. That's the average, the average. And that was. just like absolutely shocking. And to break down some of those factors, I think, firstly, a lot of people do hide their OCD symptoms. Obsessions can contain really disturbing content, thoughts about violence, sexuality, blasphemy, that's deeply upsetting. And we have been taught to believe that our thoughts reflect who we are and that we have control over our thoughts. So if we think bad things,
就像我说的，我一直在研究这个。我发现了莱比锡大学2021年的一项研究，该研究实际发现，从症状出现到人们被诊断出患有强迫症的平均年龄间隔平均为13年。13年，超过十年。这是平均水平，平均水平。这简直是绝对震撼。为了分解其中的一些因素，我认为，首先，许多人会隐藏他们的强迫症症状。强迫观念可能包含非常令人不安的内容，关于暴力、性欲、亵渎的想法，这些都让人深感不安。我们受到的教育让我们相信，我们的思想反映了我们是谁，并且我们能够控制自己的思想。所以如果我们有不好的想法，
we must be a bad person, that's actually not how our brains work. A lot of our thoughts occur unconsciously and then flowed up into our conscious mind. And it's not because we genuinely believe them. It's because our brain is just shooting out electricity and seeing where it lands. People are often really terrified. Like if I reveal these thoughts, people are going to think I'm crazy. Which, by the way, I hate that word. But that's what they think.
我们一定是个坏人。但实际上，我们的大脑并不是这样运作的。我们的许多想法都是在无意识中产生的，然后浮现到我们的意识中。这并不是因为我们真的相信它们。而是因为我们的大脑只是在发射电流，看看它落在了哪里。人们通常非常害怕。如果我透露了这些想法，人们会认为我疯了。顺便说一下，我很讨厌那个词。但他们就是这么想的。
People are going to think I'm crazy. People are going to think I'm dangerous. people are going to think that I should be institutionalized. And this immense shame and fear of misunderstanding, really huge barriers. Unfortunately, you know, there have been documented cases where individuals, especially parents struggling with intrusive thoughts about harming their children, have sought help, have said, I don't want to do these things, but I am thinking about them and I can't control the thought.
人们会认为我疯了。人们会认为我很危险。人们会认为我应该被送进精神病院。这种巨大的羞耻感和对被误解的恐惧，构成了巨大的障碍。不幸的是，你知道，有记录在案的案例表明，个人，尤其是那些与伤害孩子的侵入性想法作斗争的父母，曾寻求过帮助，曾说过：我不想做这些事情，但我在想这些，我无法控制这个想法。
Not the action, the thought. They've disclosed those to a healthcare professional, and they face devastating consequences. Instead of receiving appropriate mental health support for OCD, they have sometimes been met with suspicion, they've faced investigations, they've had their children removed from them. This really deep-rooted, I think, misunderstanding,
不是行动，是想法。他们向医疗保健专业人员透露了这些，并面临着毁灭性的后果。他们没有获得针对强迫症的适当心理健康支持，有时却遭到怀疑、面临调查，甚至孩子被从身边带走。我认为这种根深蒂固的误解，
this cultural misunderstanding, it creates a really chilling effect where those most in need of help are terrified to seek it. They're fearing these catastrophic consequences, and so you just suffer in silence. and that actually reinforces the hidden nature of OCD, especially some of its more taboo subtypes. It's the fact that our society hasn't, doesn't understand this, doesn't understand the difference between a thought, a desire, and an action, and so clumps them all together and shames people
这种文化误解，产生了一种令人不寒而栗的效应，让那些最需要帮助的人害怕去寻求帮助。他们害怕这些灾难性的后果，于是你只能默默地承受痛苦。而这实际上强化了强迫症的隐蔽本质，尤其是它一些更具禁忌色彩的亚型。事实上，我们的社会还没有、不理解这一点，不理解思想、欲望和行动之间的区别，因此将它们混为一谈，并羞辱任何
who have any of them. Nowadays, clinical guidelines do really strongly advocate for professionals to be trained in differentiating these ego-dustonic intrusive thoughts from actual intent. or risk of harm because there has been a lack of specialized knowledge in the past that has created really severe and damaging misjudgments. You know, the International OCD Foundation explicitly states that thoughts are not indicators of a person's true desire. Someone's actions are more indicative of their desire, their desire to hurt or harm people.
产生其中任何一种想法的人。如今，临床指南确实强烈主张对专业人员进行培训，以区分这些不和谐（ego-dystonic）的侵入性想法与实际意图或伤害风险，因为过去缺乏专业知识造成了非常严重和破坏性的误判。你知道，国际强迫基金会明确指出，想法并不是一个人真实欲望的指标。一个人的行动更能说明他们的欲望，说明他们伤害或危害人们的欲望。
And they've really tried to say, like, people are not their thoughts. And if they are confessing their thoughts, they obviously don't want to. to act on them. So please treat them. Please treat them not just in general in terms of give them help, but give them respect. But unfortunately, not all practitioners or even mental health clinicians are fully trained in recognizing those many diverse presentations of OCD. And it's not all their fault. You know, they might just be less familiar with certain symptoms. They may just have previous misconceptions or their own beliefs about what kind of person would have these thoughts. it does just end up though perpetuating suffering due to missed opportunities for health.
他们真的试图表达：人们不是他们的想法。如果他们在坦白自己的想法，他们显然不想付诸行动。所以请治疗他们。请治疗他们，不仅在普遍意义上给予他们帮助，还要给予他们尊重。但不幸的是，并非所有的从业人员甚至是心理健康临床医生都接受过充分的培训，能够识别强迫症的那些多种多样表现形式。这也不完全是他们的错。你知道，他们可能只是对某些症状不太熟悉。他们可能只是对什么样的人会有这些想法抱有之前的误解或他们自己的信念。不过，这最终确实因错失了获得健康的机会而让痛苦长期持续下去。
Another study that I found looked at, GP physician, like family doctors, their ability to diagnose OCD and it found that cases were misdiagnosed around 50% of the time. Someone comes in with OCD, there's a one and two chance, like a one and two chance that they're going to get the right diagnosis, which is really, really scary. And it's really crucial that they know what to look for because they're often the only entry into receiving. They are the only entry into receiving treatment. So if they miss the ball, if they miss certain symptoms, like, that's it. That's the end of the line sometimes. It's not all doom and gloom, though. I really want to make that clear. Although the road to
我发现的另一项研究考察了全科医生，也就是家庭医生诊断强迫症的能力，结果发现病例被误诊的几率约为50%。当有人带着强迫症走进诊室时，有一半的几率——就像二分之一的几率——他们会得到正确的诊断，这真的、真的很可怕。而且至关重要的一点是，他们知道该寻找什么，因为他们通常是获得治疗的唯一入口。所以如果他们失手了，如果他们错过了某些症状，那就这样了。有时这就成了死胡同。不过，这并不是世界末日。我真的很想明确这一点。尽管获取
accessing support may be tricky, OCD is highly treatable. It is one of the easiest disorders to treat. The absolute gold standard, actually, for OCD treatment is something called exposure and response prevention. It's a type of cognitive behavioral therapy, which is a very common type of therapy that is used all over the world. So ERP basically involves gradually exposing people to their biggest fears, their biggest obsessions, whilst preventing the accompanying compulsive behavior, they would usually kind of turn to reduce anxiety. So response prevention. They're preventing a certain response. And basically what they're trying to do and what this technique is trying to do is give them evidence that the worst case scenario won't happen. Because once they can see that what they're doing isn't actually doing anything,
支持的道路可能很棘手，但强迫症是高度可治疗的。它是最容易治疗的障碍之一。事实上，强迫症治疗的绝对黄金标准被称为暴露与反应预防（ERP）。这是一种认知行为疗法，这是一种在世界各地广泛使用的非常普遍的疗法。因此，ERP基本上包括逐渐将人们暴露于他们最大的恐惧、他们最大的强迫观念中，同时阻止他们通常会转向以减轻焦虑的伴随强迫行为。也就是反应预防。他们正在阻止某种反应。基本上，他们试图做的事情以及这项技术试图做的是为他们提供证据，证明最坏的情况不会发生。因为一旦他们能看到他们所做的事情实际上并没有起到任何作用，
it's not the reason that they're safe. It's not the reason that their family is protected. It's not the reason that something doesn't happen. Then they don't have to perform it as often and they can kind of just sit with the discomfort of the thought without the compulsion and see that nothing bad it's going to happen. A thought is not reality. A thought is not an action. Basically, you call your OCDs bluff. I heard an amazing analogy to sum up what this treatment really does and what it teaches people to do. Imagine you have like a snowball in your hand, right? And at first, the ice is pretty painful. Like, it's cold. It kind of burns. And you think, what if I get frostbite? What if something, my hand falls off? What if, what's going to happen? So,
这并不是他们安全的原因，这并不是他们的家人受到保护的原因，这并不是某些事情没有发生的原因，那么他们就不必那么频繁地执行它，他们可以静静地忍受对这种想法的不适感而没有强迫行为，并看到不会有什么坏事发生。想法不是现实。想法不是行动。基本上，你是在戳穿你的强迫症的虚张声势。我听到过一个绝妙的比喻来总结这种治疗的真正作用以及它教导人们做什么。想象一下，你手里拿着一个雪球，对吧？起初，冰是很痛的。就像，它很冷。它有点刺痛。你会想：如果我冻伤了怎么办？如果有什么……我的手掉下来了怎么办？如果……会发生什么？所以，
you instinctively want to let go and you want to throw it on the floor, you want to throw it away, maybe throw it at someone, but if you just wait with the snowball in your hand, the ice will gradually start to melt and it will drip away and eventually it will be gone and your hand can start to warm up again. It's going to suck having this cold thing in your hand that's freezing, but then you kind of realize, wait, this actually can't hurt me beyond the initial feeling. When I first have the thought, when I first hold the snowball, that's when it's going to hurt the most. But if I can just wait it out, if I can just have a little bit of courage and training, mental health training, there is another side to this that perhaps my anxiety and my distresses never let me see.
你本能地想要松手，你想要把它扔在地板上，你想要把它扔掉，也许扔向某人，但如果你只是拿着雪球在手里等一会儿，冰就会逐渐开始融化并滴落，最终它会消失，你的手可以开始重新变暖。手里拿着这个冻得要命的冰冷东西会很不爽，但随后你就会意识到：等等，除了最初的感觉之外，这实际上伤不到我。当我第一次有这个想法时，当我第一次拿着这个雪球时，那是它最痛的时候。但如果我能挺过去，如果我能有一点勇气和训练，心理健康训练，这里还有另一面，也许我的焦虑和痛苦从未让我看到过。
The goal is basically to learn that the feared outcome doesn't happen. And this process really gradually rewires the brain's fear response. It rewires basal gangling. it rewires parts of your frontal lobe, parts of your interior parts of your brain that are assessing situations the wrong way. Given the challenges and diagnosis and the misunderstandings we've talked about, I think being your own informed advocate is really crucial here if this is something you're going through. This means that listening to things like this, gaining more information about your specific OCD subtype is so valuable so that when you do step into the system,
目标基本上是了解到害怕的结果并不会发生。这个过程确实逐渐重塑了大脑的恐惧反应。它重塑了基底神经节，重塑了你额叶的一部分、你大脑中那些以错误方式评估情况的内侧部分。鉴于诊断方面的挑战和我们讨论过的误解，我认为，如果你正在经历这种情况，成为自己知情的维权者在这里真的至关重要。这意味着倾听像这样的内容，获得更多关于你特定强迫症亚型的的信息是如此宝贵，以至于当你真正进入这个系统时，
you freaking know your stuff. You know what you need. You know how to get to someone who knows more than you, but who will treat you with respect. And this might sound kind of harsh, but the only way to do that is kind of bypass people who actually don't know that much about your OCD, don't know much about OCD in general. So this might include getting to the appointment and just telling your GP exactly what you need and what treatment you think is helpful. Even if they might dismiss it, advocate for your desire to try that. It could mean asking for a second opinion or a referral to a specialist when you can tell someone maybe isn't specialized enough, also keeping up to date with emerging research that an average GP wouldn't have time to look at. It's not that these people are uneducated. It's not that they're
你对自己的事了如指掌。你知道你需要什么。你知道如何找到一个比你懂得更多、但会尊重你的人。这听起来可能有点刺耳，但做到这一点的唯一方法就是绕过那些其实对你的强迫症知之甚少、对总体强迫症知之甚少的人。所以这可能包括到达预约地点，并准确地告诉你的全科医生你需要什么以及你认为有什么治疗是有帮助的。即使他们可能会驳回，也要为自己想要尝试的愿望发声。这可能意味着在你能看出某人可能不够专业时，要求第二次意见或转诊给专家，还要跟进前沿研究，这是普通全科医生没有时间去看的。并不是说这些人没有受过教育。并不是说他们
cruel. It's not that they're malicious. It's that they see thousands of people a year with each of them having very specific health problems, very specific maybe even mental health problems. there are hundreds of thousands of articles coming out each year about all those specific conditions they can't necessarily keep up. But because this is impacting you and it's individual, you can and you can hopefully be able to come into those appointments knowing a little bit more. And not only can this lead the doctor in the right direction, but also it can be really empowering for you to be educated. And having psychoeducation around your symptoms and around what's happening in your brain is actually research has shown a really powerful contributor to
残忍。并不是他们有恶意。而是他们一年要见数千人，每个人都有非常具体的健康问题，甚至是非常具体的心理健康问题。每年有数十万篇关于所有这些特定情况的文章发表，他们不一定能跟上。但因为这会影响到你，而且是针对你个人的，所以你可以，而且希望你能带着对病情多一点的了解去赴约。这不仅能引导医生走向正确的方向，而且对你了解相关知识也是一种极大的赋能。研究表明，围绕你的症状以及大脑中发生的事情进行心理教育，是以下方面的一个真正强有力的促进因素：
healing and to finding relief from OCD. Also remember, if you do access support and the first professional isn't the right fit, you are actually totally allowed to say this isn't working and you are allowed to request or find someone new. You know, I did this my first person, my first couple of people when I, you know, first got my diagnosis, they didn't really understand what was happening. And they kept trying to, you know, guide me back to solutions for someone with a different type of OCD that wouldn't work for me. So I just asked to see someone else. It was really uncomfortable. It felt awkward, but I'm glad I did it because my mental health is more important than someone else's feelings and about someone else's feelings about their job
康复并找到缓解强迫症的方法。还要记住，如果你确实寻求了帮助，而第一个专业人士并不合适，你其实完全可以说“这不管用”，并且你可以要求或寻找新的人。你知道的，我第一位、前几位医生就是这样，当我刚确诊时，他们其实并不理解发生了什么。他们一直试图引导我回到针对其他类型强迫症患者的解决方案，这对我不管用。所以我只是要求看另一个人。这真的很不舒服，感觉很尴尬，但我很高兴我这么做了，因为我的心理健康比别人的感受更重要，比别人对他们工作表现的感受更重要。
performance. You know, self-advocacy. It isn't about being confrontational. It's about not wasting your own time. It's about not putting your mental health on the line for someone else to learn. from or experiment with if they don't know what they're doing. And it's also about recognizing that you are the expert of your own experience. You literally live with these thoughts every day. You have the right to informed effective care. And taking an active role, I think, really allows you to say this isn't right. This isn't working for me and ask for something better because you deserve it. I think something else to say is that OCD is not a one and done condition, unfortunately. it is something that you have to continue managing and working with. Obviously, it gets easier
你知道的，自我倡导。这并不是要去对抗。这是关于不浪费你自己的时间。这是关于不要拿你的心理健康去冒险，让别人来学习或试验，如果他们根本不知道自己在做什么的话。这也是关于认识到你是自己经历的专家。你每天都在和这些想法共处。你有权获得知情且有效的护理。我认为，扮演积极的角色真的能让你说出“这不对。这对我不管用”，并要求更好的服务，因为你配得上。我想还要说的一点是，不幸的是，强迫症不是一次性就能治愈的疾病。这是你需要持续管理和应对的事情。很显然，它会变得越来越容易
over time, but this might be a long journey for you. So don't settle in with someone who isn't going to be a good companion on that journey. Find someone who's going to be able to really meet you where you're at in terms of a mental health professional. It's going to be able to keep up to date and really care about you and know what's going on so that things do feel less sticky. Things do feel easier. Okay, I'm going to quickly finish with some resources that I personally think of really, really helpful if you have OCD. These are resources that I have engaged with, people that I follow, who I think really reduce some of the stigma and just give you more information and help you be informed in like a medical
随着时间的推移，但这可能是一段漫长的旅程。所以不要和一个在这段旅程中无法成为好伙伴的人将就。找一个真正能在心理健康专业层面上与你产生共鸣的人。一个能够跟上时代、真正关心你并了解情况的人，好让事情感觉没那么棘手。事情确实会变得更容易。好了，我将快速以一些我认为如果患有强迫症真的非常有帮助的资源来结束。这些是我接触过的资源，我关注的人，我认为他们真的减少了一些污名化，并为你提供更多信息，帮助你在医疗背景下保持知情。
context. The first is Zachary James. He is a UK creator. He runs the, I guess, handle OCD Stigmatize on Instagram. I really, really love. what this man does. I love how he talks about his own experience. I love how he talks about upcoming research, about news story mentions of OCD, about elements of it that people don't understand. So we'd really recommend him. There's also another Instagram handle such, I guess, service provider called Treat My OCD. I personally have never used their service, but I really like how they share information in a really succinct way. I also really like how they occasionally share stories of celebrities or public figures who have OCD, who talk about it in interviews or talk about it
第一个是扎卡里·詹姆斯（Zachary James）。他是一位英国创作者。他在Instagram上的账号大概是“OCD Stigmatize”。我真的非常喜欢这个男人所做的事。我喜欢他谈论自己经历的方式。我喜欢他谈论即将开展的研究、关于新闻报道中提及的强迫症、以及人们不理解的那些方面。所以我真的很推荐他。还有另一个Instagram账号，或者说服务提供商，叫做“Treat My OCD”。我个人从来没有使用过他们的服务，但我真的很喜欢他们以非常简明扼要的方式分享信息。我也非常喜欢他们偶尔分享一些患有强迫症的名人或公众人物的故事，他们在采访中或在播客中谈论这件事
on podcasts because I find hearing what other people are going through with this is such like an, it's so soothing when you're like, oh, thank God, I'm not the only one. And often, you know, celebrities are the ones who have the platform to talk about it. They recently shared some clips from Benny Blanco, Pink Panther, about OCD. I did not know. Pink Panther has pure, pure OCD, purely obsessional. And she was talking about it and I was like, wow, wow, it was this weird thing where I was like, wow, never had someone talk about it that way. So that was like quite empowering. I never thought Pink Panthers would help me with my mental health. But there we go. And then a podcast, a podcast that I think is exceptional called It's Not
因为我发现听到其他人正在经历这些，感觉就像是一个，当你听到时会感到无比宽慰，你会想：“谢天谢地，我不是唯一一个。”而且通常情况下，名人才是拥有发声平台的群体。他们最近分享了来自本尼·布兰科（Benny Blanco）、粉红豹（PinkPantheress）关于强迫症的一些片段。我之前不知道。粉红豹患有纯强迫型（pure O），即纯粹的强迫思维。她当时正在谈论这个，我就想：“哇，哇，”这是一种很奇怪的感觉，我想：“哇，从来没有人以这种方式谈论过它。”所以这相当有力量。我从未想过粉红豹会帮我解决心理健康问题。但事实就是如此。然后是一个播客，我认为这是一个极其出色的播客，叫做《这不是你想的那样》（It's Not What You Think）。他们分享了太多的故事。他们专门只谈论强迫症。他们对此有着如此精妙的方法。所以我会在下方的简介中链接所有这些内容。我只是觉得如果你在寻找一些知情的人和很酷的东西，那就是你应该去的地方。但非常感谢你的收听。如果你坚持到了这里，在下方留下一个小黄心吧。我不知道。我觉得这是一个很好的，我觉得这是一个很好的强迫症意识的小象征。请注意，我和你真的在一起面对这一切。
What You Think. They share so many stories. They specialize in only talking about OCD. They have such a brilliant approach to it. So I'll link all of these things in the description below. I just think if you're looking for some informed people and some cool stuff, that is where you should go. But thank you so much for listening. If you have made it this far, leave a little yellow heart below. I don't know. I feel like it's a nice, I feel like that's a nice little symbol of OCD awareness. Note that I'm really with you and this.
我无法想象你独自应对这一切有多么艰难。但我也曾独自应对过它。而且情况已经变得越来越好。我学到的越多，感到的宽慰就越多。所以我真的希望你能找到那种平静、和平和宁静。我相信你能做到。所以我向你在这段充满挑战的疾病旅程中的每一个阶段，送去满满的爱。
I can't imagine how hard it is for you to be dealing with this alone. But I have also dealt with it alone. And it's gotten easier. And the more I've learned, the more relief I feel. And so I really hope that you find that kind of calmness and that peace and that stillness. And I believe you can. So I'm sending you a lot of love in every single one of your journeys with this very difficult disorder.
哦，我知道这太老套了。不，你并不孤单。情况会为你变好的。外面有很多人对这种疾病了解很多，并且可以帮助你，即使前几个人什么都不知道。只要做你自己的倡导者，勇敢一点，有勇气一点。我真的祝愿你们一切都好。希望这一集对你们有所帮助。
Oh, I know it's so cliche. No, you're not alone though. It's going to get better for you. There are people who know a lot out there about this illness and can help you, even if the first couple of people don't know anything. Just be your own advocate, be brave, be courageous. And I really am wishing you all the best. I hope this episode has helped.
把它分享给你认识的、可能也会从中受益的人。如果你认为这是一个很好的资源，请务必在Instagram上关注我，账号是“that psychology podcast”。我很想听听你们的故事或你们自己与强迫症的经历，因为在这个病症和疾病方面，我还比较年轻。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些，向你们送去满满的爱。
Share it with someone that you know who might also benefit from it. If you think this was a good resource, make sure you're following me on Instagram as well at that psychology podcast. I'd love to hear your stories or your own experiences with OCD, as I am still a little young and when it comes to this condition and this disorder. and until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, and sending you so much love.
敬请期待另一集。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难的学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并艰难地学习。2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
Stay tuned for another episode. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试造假了两次，对吧？我造了一次假。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这是《受困于爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神韧性、
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the signs of mental toughness,
体能，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。记住，是“数字TWO”%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们开始采取行动。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands.
我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe）。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证人类。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。